[Music]  Sharon's fiance cherry Seaborn look  nothing short of perfect on Tuesday when  she stepped out for the first time since  the couple revealed their engagement you  are the one go did you know that it's  true  check out cherry walking in London she  looks polished and professional in her  black slacks and sweater but all eyes  are on her shiny new sparkler  on Saturday ed announced via Instagram  that he and his longtime love will tie  the knot writing we are very happy and  in love the pair has known each other  since they were kids and began dating in  2015 for you to reach I think it's cool  you know you don't you don't get away  with her you don't get away because she  can call you out on feeling younger here  we turned along with you  [Music]